foreign
person just going on campus and just
killing people
this stuff needs to stop and that's my
that's the problem it just needs to stop
because this shouldn't have happened it
didn't need to happen
they had to start locking down
everything and my friends were
barricaded with the dust because we
didn't know what was going on so we had
to be they basically had to lock down
everything and barricade themselves in
the desk for hours at end I I hope that
something changes because I hope that
other students don't have to go through
what we're going through and um
don't have to experience the changes
that we're going to experience since we
did have a mass shooting and it was
someone that didn't go here it was 43
years old had no affiliation to us so
it's just a random a random human being
just came in
you know we were scared to go by the
windows we didn't want to be seen we
didn't want to be potentially targeted
Through the Windows but we had to shut
our blinds we had to turn off lights and
we turned off all the lights and then we
had to try to move everything quietly
with our lights off and windows closed
doors locked as much as we could get
them and just shoving our dressers and
our chairs and any other miscellaneous
bits and bobbles we had last night timel
said run hide fight and that was sort of
the moment me and my roommates kind of
realized like this is different you know
this is like something serious this time
it came here it like reached us so
I mean we all know what's been happening
in the country and all the shootings so
you just
it's it's scary that you're kind of
ready for that a moment to say our our
hearts are with the students and the
families of Michigan State University
last night I spoke with Governor Whitmer
and uh the FBI and additional federal
law enforcement are on the ground
assisting in state local folks and uh
three lives have been lost and five
seriously injured
and it's a family's worst nightmare it's
happening far too often this country
far too often
while we gather more information there's
one thing we do know to be true
we have to do something to stop gun
violence ripping apart our communities
and many of us have gone through the
Grim exercise of figuring out who our
last call would be to
last night a lot of kids on this campus
made those calls
they worried for their lives and for
their friends
for their fellow Spartans
parents across Michigan were on pins and
needles
calling their kids to tell them that
they love them
as parents we tell our kids it's going
to be okay
we say that all the time
but the truth is words are not good
enough
we must act and we will all five
individuals remained in critical
condition this morning
the team was led by our emergency
department Physicians again with our our
trauma surgeons but uh can't uh forget
we had general surgeons
cardiothoracic surgeons neurosurgeons
that didn't get a lot of sleep last
night sorry
so many people that uh
just came in
the uh received a lot of texts that were
just uh you know I'm on my way just
within people showing up where do you
need me it was it was it was a sad but
uh
I'm very proud night for all of us here